chuck you haven't been stuck in the same
orbital plane let me tell you i if i had
a dime for every moment of sleep i've
lost
over single lawn sat cubes i would be
ugh
that'd actually be very well refreshed
[Music]
this is star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist i got with me chuck nice
as usual my co-host chuck how you doing
man hey neil what's happening all right
we got it we got a tasty episode today
oh my gosh
data
from space all right coming down to
earth going in
back to space okay how does it happen
who's doing it why are we doing it i'm
sorry to say
that's every episode we do
okay
that is true
we're bringing the universe down to
earth yes that is what we do
we get a lot of inquiries about cubesats
and nanosatellites all of these things
yes and we figured it's time to go to
the source or at least one of the more
important sources of the world
of
who's been obtaining data and how they
do it and let's just get right
to it
we're going to we're going to talk to
one of the vice presidents of raytheon
technology
totally sandra brown welcome to star
talk thank you it's so nice to be here
neil and chuck excellent excellent so
you're vice president of what for
raytheon right i am vice president of a
mission area called digital emissions
solutions which is a part of our larger
space and command and control business
so essentially we develop space-based
sensors ground systems precision
navigation and timing uh processing data
sense making multi-domain tactical you
know and strategic command and control
we also do a little environmental and
climate centers earth observation
missile warning and defense structures
okay so nothing gets by you basically
nothing gets biased let me let me let me
just say we'll lock down
here's what i just heard is that space
is a business right now that's what i
just heard well it is true big business
yeah when people typically think of
space they think of nasa yeah but if you
look at nasa's budget which is small as
a fraction of our
gdp compared with the apollo era but
it's still but it's still many billions
but it's it's very small what kind of
projects are you working on now uh well
specifically in my area we have a lot of
extremely cool stuff and that's a
technical term uh we're building the
next generation of ground systems uh
we're supporting the critical weather
and earth observation instruments and of
course laying the foundation for
commanding and controlling satellites
can you tell me what ground systems are
i'm not i know you said that but i don't
know what that is chuck the system's on
the ground
you're like uh chuck they're systems in
the air
and they're systems above the air we
call that space
and then you got the stuff on the ground
okay that's the ground system all right
right right so when when you're talking
about satellite commanding control
you're really talking about four things
you're talking about an operation center
you're talking about a ground station um
you're talking about the ground network
and you're talking about the satellite
and that's how you know ground station
allows you to actually communicate with
that satellite via the operation center
okay okay so these these are these are
radio microwave dishes or something
right i mean that's
they're basically telescopes right
basically telescopes right right right
and and what wavelength bands do you
work in is it uh because we're
we're somewhat wavelength fluent in in
the show right so we would like to hear
it um a predominantly l-band but we do
have some other bands that we work in
and l-band is in the microwave part of
the spectrum is that correct correct
okay and and what role did you play with
jwst because that's been in all the news
right and delightfully so i mean i love
it when our stuff when my people you
know make headlines you know it's like
those are my people out there
i feel good yeah it means that there's a
genuine curiosity in the public and
what extent have you helped to serve
that
well have you seen the images released
from jupiter i mean i don't need to be a
world-renowned astrophysicist to
understand how incredible capturing
those images are to science uh it's so
exciting for me to see every new image
created and captured by james webb for
our part raytheon intelligence and space
installed the web's ground control
system at the space telescope science
institute in baltimore
uh so the grounds yeah so the ground
system primarily responsible for
maintaining the health and safety of the
observatory and supports the command and
control of the telescope
so essentially our software receives the
observation data and transfers
information to the system that is
accessible to astronomers and other
scientists so at the risk of stating the
obvious sandy um in principle
nasa could have
done all of this from scratch
but when they look at the landscape of
space technologies that are out there
they say well we want to talk to our
telescope who does it best and then they
they shop around and there's raytheon
and so then you then install your ops
and you probably your people are there
too right absolutely right however i
will i will say that
from a business model it doesn't make
sense just to do this for nasa so the
other applications have to be there and
what would those be so you're looking at
these you know the building blocks i
mean we have the people that have been
doing you know programming systems
engineering the integration for a very
long time so we use those building
blocks specific to um support our
customers requirements so we're not ever
having to start from scratch um specific
to the james webb our software you know
we reused where we could uh but that
software um is used to rebuild the
images that we
that we receive from the james webb
we program the coding languages
necessary to take those ones and zeros
and make them images for our human eyes
to see um so we're using a lot of the
you know the optical um
technologies that we've already
developed a lot of you know reuse from
other programs and we just really
customize it to fit the need of the
james webb
and and
again at the risk of stating the obvious
but it's i mean it's a historical thing
and absolutely at length about this but
i want to hear it from the horse's mouth
isn't it true
that i've been a big part of raytheon's
portfolio's defense systems but
you also have scientists and the
engineering that supports science uh
leading another kind of communications
or data frontier and they each feed each
other in a kind of a two-way street
isn't that correct
that's absolutely correct
okay
okay
so i heard you say a lot about code code
code code
code code code code
so that with all of what you do
which a lot of it irrespective of if
it's defense or not
is sensitive
what what are you guys are are you also
working in like hardening
cyber security because i would think
that would be very important
oh yeah
it's extremely important
[Laughter]
i appreciate that check no it's
extremely important it's built into
every product that we build it's a part
just a part of our design process it's
not something that we add on as an extra
layer we really you know start our every
development project starts with cyber in
mind so we can deliver that solution to
our customers to ensure that they have
uninterrupted services um you know and
we can deter when we need to deter
wow okay but can you protect yourself
against an asteroid i bet you can't i
bet you can't
i look to you
what's your code what's your code for
that sandy
i want to provide you the data from
space so you can interpret it and
provide us the answers of when that
thing's going to hit and where oh or
deflect it so that it never hits correct
absolutely so i got a question okay in
leo low earth orbit the satellites you
can watch them move across the sky so if
i if i'm using them for like internet or
something that i would want or expect to
be stable
what happens when that is has gone past
my horizon
there must be some system of handoffs
from one satellite to another and you
must have a bajillion of them so that i
always have a few over my head is that
correct or do you just get us did you
just get a message on your screen that
says hey see you tomorrow in three
it's right two and tune in
[Laughter]
you have a great number to get the
consistency of service absolutely
okay and a great number can you quantify
that as like hundreds of thousands
thousands thousands thousands of these
small stats performing you know
different capabilities and and sharing
data in order to make sure that you have
that coverage plus you all took another
one of my words now you're taking the
word constellation because you call
these satellites constellations it's
like no i'm not giving you that you took
it anyway
it's way too late we're too late
do they make interesting shapes are they
greek mythology no they're just a train
of satellites however
sandy and your defense
in your defense
raytheon doesn't need anyone in their
defense okay they are their own defense
system yeah but that's kind of cool
chuck nice defends
okay go go what
he's the defense system for raytheon oh
my god okay anyway no so when you look
at a constellation no one sees the
pictures that are drawn anyway so that's
true that's true except astrophysicists
they're the only ones no no look right
no i don't yeah i don't see it i don't
see a crab okay
and we
and we have a whole business that does
nothing but launch these satellites into
the orbits as well
right so so now are you worried about
how crowded it's getting what is the
future ecology what is the future
ecology of space launches yeah i mean
that's a topic that we often discuss
with our customers there's you know it's
a proliferation of space the space
debris the space junk we have to be very
you know cognizant of what that could
mean if we have collisions in space for
especially our you know our higher
capability satellites we have sensors on
those satellites to make sure that we
can steer clear of one another and
that's important and we you know rate
that raytheon we do develop those
sensors to make sure that um we have the
situational awareness of where they are
well just disappointing you're in orbit
moving five miles per second what do you
mean steer clear you can actually
navigate these things while you're
absolutely doing that
oh my gosh
so if you connect that means they each
have a reserve of fuel
that presumably would eventually run out
correctly it does they do right and then
we are not able to move them at it
anymore but we're looking at
technologies you know like solar or um
actually the ability to refuel
satellites as well wow
so do you they are but they are on board
with or they are on board with a very
limited amount of fuel absolutely so
when
will there be enough satellites in orbit
you know um our customers say n plus one
okay that continues to infinity by the
way for as long as you want to know how
that works mathematically
whatever the n is give me one more all
right yep there's constant evolution of
technology and you know we have to do uh
you know just as you do on the ground we
do modernization um we do replacement
activities so
um you know we want to make sure that we
keep up with current threats so we can
again deter and defend
so what do you do about collecting your
um
outdated materials yeah yeah that's
right because because i i don't use a
computer from three years ago right
because it doesn't have the capabilities
i want yet you surely have satellites
that are three years old so how do you
do how do you deal with with the
obsolescence given the fast-moving
frontier right right now we don't have a
cleanup crew for space so um they either
you know burn in burn into the
atmosphere um or they stay up there and
again you know that's what we refer to
as space junk
right so leo you can burn up eventually
but right middle middle earth
the dragon keeps them okay right right
the dragon keeps them
orbit okay so uh what is the split would
you say uh i don't need to get all into
your your
your your ledgers but what is what is
your split between the private use of
space and the government use of space
because presumably obviously you serve
both communities
we are predominantly government we are
predominantly you know defense
okay but you know one influences the
other obviously so we we utilize and we
leverage commercial technologies to
serve our defense customers oh so what
about space war because you're looking
at all this information now that is just
sitting above us
in low earth orbit what is to say like
okay i'm somebody else i'm like i'll
just capture a few of your uh satellites
your little cubesats and i'll get all
that proprietary information for myself
well that's kind of what space force is
for also i would think right absolutely
protecting assets either you know
government assets or business assets but
what else would you want your
well and that's why we build in right
and that's why we build in cyber
security measures from the beginning of
every design so sandy what is your what
is your sort of academic profile that
landed you where you are today
you know i have a business degree with a
minor in information systems um but you
know as a ten-year-old girl i had my
commodore 64 computer um with my black
and white television set you know teeing
in the hello world uh program when i was
you know again when i was really young
and so that technology kind of um
my interest in technology you know has
grown throughout the years but that was
your technology baptism right that was
my baptism right exactly waiting every
month for that you know coding magazine
to come so i could translate the
magazine set into my little commodore
64. um and i just followed the evolution
of technology and it's safe the the 64
in commodore 64 is 64k
right right
64k
and that was like yeah
all i wanted for christmas uh you know
and so
that that eventually led me on my career
path yep yeah yeah and you know lately
i've been hearing the word systems
referred to
uh and i think
because so many different bits and
pieces have to cooperate
in technology there's a whole new kind
of engineer that i think
at least when i was a kid there wasn't
much discussion about but now it's
everywhere just comment on systems
engineering and what that means for in
your job and just for the for the role
of the company yeah absolutely it's just
it's a broader field i mean you have to
understand how the the different parts
and pieces fit together uh to form the
whole you you know it's desirable to
have a background in
some you know coding so you understand
how the program uh and and hits the bus
and how that
is all you know put together again to
develop a product
and it's not just you know you can't be
stoved pipe in your disciplines anymore
you really have to have that broader
view of hardware software and again the
systems to build the system of systems
as well
gotcha i mean isn't that just what an
iphone is right an iphone has gps it has
touchscreen it has computers it's got
music it's got uh it's so it's a system
of systems really
and maybe we
so i'm just impressed by that because it
used to be i have this one thing that
does this one thing right
right and then i hook it to another
thing that does another thing and then
they do the thing together
that's the beginnings of it right right
and so radiant intelligence in space we
actually are building a framework very
similar to an iphone to take data from
space and different space vehicles and
be able to put applications on a layer
and be able to
manipulate data and take the data from
space that we are receiving and
deliver weather to deliver missile
warning missile defense deliver
uh gps coordinates the real question is
how how good is the camera
how good is the camera i have to get
back to you
actually in our environment no cameras
are allowed okay wow
so here's here's something
you guys are known pretty much for you
know drones and that's everybody's like
raytheon the first thing that pops into
your head you know pilotless vehicles i
mean aircraft
what do you do in all this stuff that
would touch people's lives that they
don't even know
every morning
yeah every morning when you pick up your
cell phone and you look at the weather
we have a role in that when you
uh turn on your
apple map application and want to go to
the grocery store and want to avoid
traffic we have a part in that that
navigation and timing
um so and we're making that blue dot on
your screen more accurate
because we are modernizing the gps um
ground stations
all right wow
that's okay listen that's that's very um
in that you're you're very integral to a
lot of people's daily lives then right
right right so wake up in ways again in
ways that people don't even imagine yeah
racial intelligence in space kind of
showing up well sandy's been a delight
to have you and it gets such a
deep representation in such an important
company in this world that's taking us
into the future and
keeping us safe while we do so so thanks
for being a guest
all right chuck we're not done here
we've got uh carrie cahoy coming up
who's gonna tell us more about uh what
it is to make these satellites and what
they do and why and what the future of
it will be when star talk continues
from the james webb space telescope to
next generation gps ground control to
global climate monitoring raytheon
intelligence in space is engineering
solutions that make our lives on earth
better smarter safer and more connected
everyday space is changing and every day
raytheon intelligence and space teams
push the edges of discovery to help
drive that change for customers around
the world from the ground up if you're
enjoying this episode and want to learn
more about how raytheon intelligence and
space is advancing space solutions make
sure to head over to
www.raytheonintelligenceandspace.com
we're back star talk all about
satellites who's launching them who's
designing them what are they doing how
many are there
uh do we need more do we need less
all of this is what this show is about
and for the next two segments we're
going to have someone where that is her
life
professor kerry kahoe kerry welcome to
star talk
thank you so much for having me it's a
pleasure to be here excellent excellent
so your associate professor of
aeronautics and astronautics at mit for
those who are not academic fluent is the
massachusetts institute of technology
and i also have more on your resume here
co-director of mit small satellite
center
okay and you're a leader in mit star lab
that's one of those fancy acronyms space
telecommissions telecommunications
astronomy and radiation laboratory star
lab and used to be a nasa research
scientist so you are the right person
for these two segments for us to get
into
what's going on here first let me ask
let me ask you this before we get into
it when are you going to do something
with your life
[Laughter]
i have these i have these questions
myself
so first tell us the difference between
aeronautics and astronautics
so one is about flying planes and the
other is about flying spacecraft okay so
air and space is the major difference
okay all right um
but if you're really into satellites
what do you care about aeronautics all
right
how low do you want to fly
mic drop
somebody doing a rap battle right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn wow that's great though okay
and where do you want to land and what
do you have to go through for entry
descent and landing they're connected
you have to go through one to get to the
other okay so so tell me about the star
lab because the r stands for radiation
in there too and people are spooked by
the word radiation but space
telecommunications astronomy and
radiation so what does the star lab do
so we test new technologies in space um
using small platforms like cubesats or
nanosatellites and we also support
projects for
government and industry partners
to
have larger missions like large space
telescopes we'll do some of the analyses
um that they need to make their missions
happen or answer questions that they're
having a hard time with or would like a
new approach to or a problem they need
to solve so that acronym star that's
it's a catch basin for everybody who
needs you because you do all those
different things
yeah there are some things that we
specialize in a little bit more than
others but um
there's a lot of different disciplines
that you need to be successful in space
and what about you know what's missing
here and maybe you can repurpose the t
in star how about thermodynamics
because this is a big challenge yeah
could you go from room temperature on
earth surface to space cold and then
like you're facing the sun and then
you're hot again i mean the your stuff
has to work in a wide variety of
temperatures do you have those testing
centers as well those testing um
platforms yeah yeah one of the key tests
for a satellite is to make sure that the
heaters turn on when they're supposed to
so you have these chambers where you try
to get the temperatures
low enough using um liquid nitrogen or
if you have to get really cold liquid
helium or something like that to get
those temperatures cold and trigger your
sensors to turn on heaters um to keep
your satellite alive mostly mostly the
batteries need to stay happy batteries
hate being cold wow while they're
operating they hate to be cold because
when i grew up you kept batteries in the
refrigerator and the refrigerator
remember that to
preserve them to preserve them yeah if
you're if you're yeah yeah
you know what i learned i was up in
alaska um and my wife is was raised in
alaska and
there's
friends and relatives still up there
that we were run using some flashlight
and the batteries went dead and and one
of the these like
bear wrestling mountain
persons
persons i got this and he takes the
batteries out and he
rubs them in his hands rolling them back
and forth does this for about 90 seconds
we put the batteries back in the
flashlight it worked again it was like
magic this is like
what what what neil didn't know is he
was an alien
he used an emp
no way he didn't tell me that
so so why why are satellites small
because i remember in the day
in my day satellites were at least as
big as a person uh possibly the size of
a car
uh why is why what's the rush to make
them all little
well i like satellites of any size and i
started off like you're saying
satellites the size of a greyhound bus
and they have little ladders that we
crawl up to like work on the panels in
there
so some satellites have staircases and
ladders but um
the the making them small helps because
the idea is you can get more of them on
orbit
and that's in a single launch in a
single one
well
you know i have mixed feelings about
that because if you go on a single
launch you're stuck in a single orbit
plane and then you have this like string
of satellites and it doesn't get all the
orbit planes you want i hate it when
that happens you know yeah
chuck you haven't been stuck in the same
orbital plane let me tell you i if i had
a dime for every moment of sleep i've
lost
over
single lawn sat cubes i would be ugh
that'd actually be very well refreshed
so what's going on because we've seen
we've all seen these youtube videos of
the
deployed satellites from a single
mission and they're all just lined up
there like a train yeah
one following another and so you you
value different orbital uh trajectories
i do i like different orbit planes
because then i don't have to wait for
the same guys to sweep around the earth
and precess around and then i have
multiple of them that can cover
different places at the same time or
close to the same turn and i don't have
to wait for them to swing around did you
ever consider using something you know
bill nye some time ago neil was on the
show and did uh the thing about the
light sale because he was along with his
organization was launching a light sail
oh yeah that was the planetary society
thank you so this would be this this
would be using light pressure with you
deploy a huge sail
of their highly reflective sound using
the pressure from light to
alter your orbit to something new so now
i guess you could also use fuel but
light sales you get to do that for free
so what what kind of what kind of what
stuff goes on in your labs
along those lines
um so we we generally don't work too
hard at um
maneuvering them although we we do have
a uh a small satellite that's on space
station right now that's about to be
deployed that's going to test a um
electrospray propulsion system on a
cubesat
um but
for the most part
those systems um
are pretty
intricate and but very necessary and
the smaller they are especially some of
the electrospace systems the
they can't really move you very far
sometimes or if they can it takes a long
time so that's kind of the trade either
um you're small and you don't go very
far it might take a long time for you to
change your orbit parameters or you need
um these big satellites which most
people think of satellites and they
don't realize
what's in the middle
but it's kind of like a
boston cream-filled donut where the
center is just a fuel tank most
satellites have this giant spherical
fuel tank in the middle the big ones
because they need to maneuver and then
they just slap some boards around the
outside with electronics on them um
i never knew i never thought yeah
yeah so so it's it's it's it's crunchy
on the outside and soft on the inside
it's sloshing on me
on the inside yeah
and and what kind of fuel is it is it
like hydrazine or what yeah there
there's monopropellants and hydrazine
that they use what's hydrazine please
do we have to explain it to you chuck
yes you do
two
two space professionals in here so yeah
uh what kind of propulsion are you using
huh yeah
what is that what do you got there what
is that it's like chuck stay with it
okay is that the work there is that what
you're doing slow down for you yeah
what's hydrazine though really what is
it it's um a compound that's very
reactive and volatile and um you reacts
to
the heat so you you basically combust it
and then you use the heat and pressure
generated by it to create a force to
move you that's it okay it's highly
reliable i mean they used it throughout
apollo that's it and it's it's it
doesn't require weird
ignition to make it right
but they do make you keep it in a bunker
or something like that yeah it's pretty
nasty stuff
it's nasty stuff if it does what you
don't want it to do but when i got it
but it's otherwise highly uh reliable so
do you focus on
so far we've only talked about uh the
hardware do you focus on any broader
scientific
uh
agricultural
environmental
goals as you think about your satellites
yeah so so i we do
focus on
enabling people to communicate so we do
optical technology for laser
communication to help people talk to
each other from anywhere securely
usually safely like optical lasers using
them yeah but if there's a cloud in the
way then then like that is good
you're not doing yourself you're not
doing yourself a very good service here
you're just like uh guys i'd love to
talk to you but it's a little cloudier
cloudy today yeah no i think hybrid
radio and optical systems are important
but one of the things we work on is
maybe just to be clear because radio
waves move through clouds right whereas
visible light well correct they still
get attenuated and the shorter the
wavelengths get the worse the clouds
treat them right um
but i gotta tell chuck why wait chuck
the shorter the wavelengths get used to
get into microwaves and
and clouds are made of what
they uh water droplets water water
droplets okay water vapor and so
so water and microwaves have a very long
history together
yeah that's how you get microwave ovens
so
uh the fact that you have that
interaction enables microwave ovens to
begin with so exactly so you need a
wavelength that passes over
the water droplets so that as though the
water droplets aren't there okay so go
on cool yeah so it needs to be longer
than that but we we're working on making
these terminals very small and so you
can put a lot of them up and
relay the lasers around the weather
systems and also making ground stations
that are small and portable so you can
have a bunch of them on the ground so
that you can receive the data that's
been sent around the weather okay so
basically it's a
an interconnected network but you break
it up all over the place that's cool no
but wait a minute so why can't it still
go to a centralized network and then you
get it by cell phone carrier or
something
you could you could definitely treat it
that way too well you make me carry a
whole big radio receiver dish with me
where i
don't do that don't worry
well you know some some people have
security needs and you don't want
anybody else to look at their data now
it comes out
right and it's not only the guys you
think about some of it is these high
frequency traders and they don't want
you to know about their data either
right well that makes sense right yeah
so are you
thinking about the cost of these things
so a number i've always heard for nasa
was ten thousand dollars a pound to put
something in low earth orbit update me
on that number for what it is you do
so cubesats right now um if i were going
to try to put a
10 pound um cubesat into orbit would be
about 200 dollars so it's it's it's
within a factor of a couple i think uh
yeah
where you are as we say in my world it's
within a factor of pi yeah yeah how do
we do it volume
right so so right now it's twenty
thousand dollars a pound what you're
saying if i did that's correct yes which
is ten thousand a kilogram ish i guess
so yeah yeah okay so that's the same
ballpark all right so we haven't that
hasn't changed much over the years so
but um is that because of gas prices and
inflationary care is that what's going
on here
gas prices inflation just
screwing up everything right
the big launch vehicles costs are coming
down though it used to be well over 100
million dollars sometimes closer to 150
200 million to launch a rocket and with
the reusability that um companies like
spacex are
really making possible now that cost is
coming down significantly if you flew to
europe in a 747 and then they shoved it
off the cliff and then brought out a new
one every time that that flight would be
really costly to you
so
yeah so i think the one of the frontiers
that spacex is pioneering is how cheap
can you get it by reusing and having
many launches within various windows
because everybody's on payroll right so
if i can launch five times instead of
once
the total salary that everyone earned is
the same but i now got five satellites
out of it instead of one so all these
things scale in ways that drop the price
yeah yeah and that's a really important
point too a lot of people don't realize
that the cost of sending things to space
is mostly the people time to put it
together and run it so that's a really
good point
right right and let me just say if you
uh if you have disposable 747s you are a
baller okay
and you take up a lot of room when you
fly right right we got to take a quick
break when we come back uh kerry uh
rumor has it that you have some interest
and care
for exoplanets and i want to get further
into that when we return start talk
segment three all about satellites when
we return
we're back star talk segment three all
about satellites
and i've got kerry kahoe here who's a
on the faculty at mit and she's one of
their
systems engineers uh studying uh should
i call you a systems engineer satellite
engineer that's what you are a little
little above or a lot of a lot of both
probably actually
so
i'm told that little birdie told me that
you also have an interest in the
detection of exoplanets and we know that
jwst is going to help uh blow that open
but we're not so much detecting them as
much as observing them once we know
they're there so how do you plug into
that turning wheel right now
yeah so jwst has some great tools for
characterizing exoplanets on board um
mostly by looking at
exoplanets um and their transits and
different things like that in different
colors and learning from
the
difference in the colors that are
observed a little bit more about the
properties of the atmosphere
i'm interested in
looking at
star systems and seeing if there are
planets around them and how many there
are and also characterizing their
atmospheres by looking at the the colors
and their relative strengths
and
the
technology you need to do that
um
very effectively for earth-like planets
means that you have to meet have
something on board the satellite that
can block out the starlight in the
middle so you can kind of see around it
where you think the habitable planets
would be
and so this is the firefly in the
searchlight problem right there there is
that analogy yeah yeah yeah if you're
trying to detect the firefly and you're
looking at one of these hollywood
searchlights it's gonna be really hard
if not impossible unless you figure out
a way to blot out the searchlight and so
this is this is also one of your big
challenges
right and i also can't assume that the
firefly glows by itself
okay so it's even harder wow right right
so i need to see the light that's
bouncing off the firefly when it's not
blinking um
come to tell me more about it
so you this is you're doing this in
addition to your satellite work see i'm
going to repeat chuck's earlier comment
you know uh
really this is all you've done in your
life yeah
it's what big slackers here's what
here's what i'm saying
stop making us all look so bad
it takes so many different types of
people to make anything happen and i'm
glad to be in a place where there is
such a variety of people with so many
different talents to throw at these
things because we need them all
um
so mit is geek central so you've got
you're in arm's reach of anybody who
knows anything
that you need to know
to
to make stuff happen yeah i think of
like mit is like the hogwarts of
technology
i love some of those moving staircases
then
animated
paintings that's totally what you want
so carrie tell us about your uh your
background getting to where you are
oh yeah so
i had a dad who was an electrician i'm
not an engineer but he you know fixed
machines
and um wired houses and did stuff like
that and i was his
not not wiring them to eavesdrop do you
mean no
literally i don't think so okay
and if he did he wouldn't have told me
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and um yeah and my you know my mom was a
um
teacher as well which you know it comes
in handy because a lot of the students
and things that i do supervising and
writing papers really it needs that
skill set very much too because you have
to communicate what you do but my dad
would help let me help around the house
and you know
was always into the latest computers and
gadgets and
um so were you a kid were you a geek
um kid yeah
yeah okay you don't have to you don't
have to be sheepish about it that's a
bad honor
and the real question is do you do your
own electrical work
at home yeah
occasionally um occasionally i i've done
things like replace
bridge sensors and garage door openers
um but i don't have as much time as i'd
like to but sometimes
you have some stuff chuck the point is
she could if she wanted to she has
better things to do
make that clear all right
all right all right and so and after so
then you went to college what'd you
major in
electrical engineering so my dad
yeah my dad
didn't go finish college and um if i you
know i think if he had he would have
wanted to do that so i kind of did that
for him wow so so if you could take
everything that you know
what
is the one advancement that you would
bring to satellite technology
that would change everything
um
do i have to only take one no no it
doesn't have to just be one just a thing
just a thing you know i want two things
i want two things um i want um the
satellite equivalent of space wi-fi
oh snap nice so that's one thing i want
and then i want the satellite equivalent
of gas stations
okay
filling station
so those are those are the two things i
want okay we need that for for space
travel in general otherwise you know
we're stuck with the rocket equation we
did a whole the chuck i think we did an
explainer on the rocket we did
yeah yeah yeah
um
and even artemis you know it's is 35
stories tall
and it's basically all fuel right
basically you need the fuel to burn to
carry the fuel that you haven't burned
yet that you're going to burn to carry
the fuel you haven't burned yet so right
if you have filling stations that that's
a game changer
but yeah but but kerry you have to
refill the filling stations
yes
yes you do have to refill the filling
stations sometimes this has become a
bigger problem
than i thought even
this just keeps getting worse
we're going to have to look at these
asteroids and um you know lagrange
points and trying to figure out how to
put stations on them and get to and from
these things with enough fuel and and
you know very efficient
systems and and or make sense make ways
to um use solar energy um
if possible for foreign or come up with
a different fuel right
well it's still a fuel i mean you need a
whole new thing that's what i mean but
when i say different source of energy
source of source thank you thank you
i said
yeah i was very inarticulate so yeah we
don't need we don't mean ethanol versus
you know gasoline versus whatever right
we're talking
warp drives captain
that's what i really want to do there
so uh we've mentioned this before which
i think many people don't know uh
engineering has
two terminal degrees one of them is the
undergraduate degree plenty of working
people with a terminal undergraduate
degree and a master's you're back in a
university as an engineer does that mean
you got a phd
it does it does i did get a phd i didn't
know that i was going to do that
honestly until probably my senior year
won't stop with the humble brats
i just can't you can't let it go
yeah i got a phd you know i didn't even
know i was gonna do it i thought he was
just happy yeah
one day i woke up one day
by the way
i don't even know how this happened i i
tripped going up the stairs and i would
well there you have it a nobel prize
how's that happen
how'd that even happen
[Music]
so i think no but here's the the reason
why there there's so few engineers with
a phd right is because if you get a phd
and you work in a university you get
paid way less than you'd otherwise get
paid in industry
yeah big problems that's a bit it's an
issue
this is a
big problem freedom and salary freedom
yeah yeah do you want
do you want to you know you want to work
for the man
as they say or do you want to be you be
your own boss and
um and as an academic i mean i i cherish
the academic life because i can say what
i want and do what i want and go where i
want um so it's but you need both right
because somebody's got to get the job
done at the end of the day on budget on
time very much so for a customer and and
the free thinkers aren't another part of
this and
without the free thinkers there wouldn't
be anything for the businesses to to
jump on i mean we need you guys i agree
though that in this industry is very
important and um it's you need people
with those types of infrastructures and
resources to make it happen
with raytheon for example they just
recently not too long maybe a couple
years ago bought a small satellite
company called blue canyon that you know
i built payloads and integrated taylors
on and operated them on orbit so you
need you need sometimes you want to take
your university project and your
research and put it on something that
someone's already built
and someone who's got pockets deep
enough to do interesting things that's
right for sure we've got to end it here
kevin's been delight to chat with you
it's good to know that you exist in this
world thinking about these problems uh
down on earth that end up in space
and uh maybe if you if you make some uh
if you invent some new kind of satellite
tell us first and we'll get you put you
on i will i'm so grateful that you guys
are here to help communicate these
concepts and do such a good job of
making it fun so okay very much look i
think the universe is a hilarious place
that's why and chuck agrees
all right we're going to we're going to
end it there all right carrie do we find
you on social media you have a do you
have a
i do have a twitter um mit star lab
okay cool yep and um
not not a personal twitter so much but
my lab keeps me busy
yeah good so we can keep track of your
lab
there yeah very good very good and chuck
you're still a chuck nice comic thank
you sir yes sir you on your social media
handles all right i'm neil degrasse
tyson you've been listening to possibly
even watching star talk
as always keep looking up
[Music]
you